what do you think those for 10 years
whatever it was taught you about the
business oh well absolutely everything I
knew nothing I knew nothing when I
started working at new line I was you
know in my early 20s I was a grad
student and I just like stories I knew
nothing about the industry filmmaking
thinking about market shares and
audience and business and and it was a
very good discipline I think what it
taught me first and foremost is to be
accountable and responsible that as a
storyteller you can tell whatever story
you want but you have to know who you're
speaking to you have to know how is your
story offering something new and who
wants to hear it and then to
realistically assess how many of those
people want to hear this story and
budget accordingly as opposed to some
creative artistic entitlement you know
I've got a great vision and I should be
given money like from a de Medici you
know rather hey this is your asking
somebody to invest in a business venture
you're asking somebody to give you a
whole heck of a lot of money to say
something be responsible for that be
responsible to that and assess it
accurately and I think that that's that
kind of a paradigm of reality based
respectful consideration of everybody's
part that everybody is working together
it's not like the big bad money guy and
a mean distributor everybody is the same
goal to tell stories and to share them
with an audience now how we all got to
make that work together and being
mutually respectful that if he's coming
to the table with the same goal
different points of view on it how can
we the more that you understand
everybody's point of view the better off
everybody will be and you'll be as a
storyteller so for me the fantastic
discipline that we had that was really
unique was that at new line unlike many
other more traditionally organized
Studios the the production division
wasn't isolated the way it worked is
that it was more like we were
functioning like independent producers
within the company
here's how so if I had a project that I
was passionate about like for example
house party I had to take the project to
the guy who's the head of marketing the
guy was head of distribution look I was
head of the ancillary media DVD at that
time VCR the guys had a foreign and say
here's the project what's it worth to
you what's worth you what's worth to you
how can you sell it what do you think
the audience is bring it back and see if
that justified the budget and then you
go into a meeting with Bob and say
here's my numbers here's their numbers
doesn't make sense or not it was very
disciplined and I got to learn a lot and
think like they thought so was I going
to produce your school which of course
is incredibly important as a filmmaker
we don't exist in isolation I am wildly
against the prototype of the indulged
artist you know who sits on a pedestal
and is like a Pasha carried forth you
know no we're in this together in a
collaborative medium where it's very
important to understand what everybody
is doing why they're doing it and work
together so I think that's the biggest
thing that I learned in a healthy
respect
you